so cosmology is the area that I'm really
fascinated about because it's an area
that connects deep philosophical
questions with hard data and the
philosophical questions they concern the
origin of the universe
and that also means the origin of space
and time if you would have asked me
three years ago how I would judge the
chance of inflation being part of the
story I would have said well more than
50 percent but it's worthwhile exploring
Alternatives because ethereum grows
by being challenged with Alternatives
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]
all right so we'll get started right now
um with my good friend My Mentor from
way back when one of my thesis committee
members one of my favorite members the
second one to appear on the podcast
Professor Robert brandenberger second
only to Peter timby who is my actual
thesis advisor who did appear on the
podcast
um many years ago on Father's Day
because as you know Robert there's sort
of a fatherly motherly connection
between a student and their mentor and I
certainly feel that way about you
although you're not old enough to be my
father but sort of like a cool Rich
Uncle uh anyway Robert how are you today
sounds like well
it's very sabbatical you oh that's great
and you're in McGill now you're in uh
you're in Montreal yeah I'm in Canada
but uh but on Sunday I'm heading back to
uh Europe
very nice I'm originally from
Switzerland right like going home that's
right that's right
spend some time at the beach or in the
walking the mountains and thinking about
things yes and I remember you walking
around the corridors of Barris and Holly
uh you were an inspiration to to me and
many time past guests Stefan Alexander I
just had the pleasure of um spending
some time doing some some thought
calculations with Stefan this past
weekend for mother's day he visited here
uh and so Robert uh We've uh connected
again uh because of a very very
interesting scenario which was that on
the website Reddit which has a lot of
crazy stuff but some interesting stuff
about physics there was a paper about uh
about your work one of your papers was
the trending topic that means it was the
most most viewed most talked about Topic
in all of all of physics and uh I
thought that was pretty much a sign that
I was overdue to have you on the podcast
stuff I've actually had a note in my
calendar I checked it from November 2020
uh so I beg your forbearance and
forgiveness for not having you on sooner
but we're not going to talk about that
paper which is about converting uh
gravity to light or maybe the other way
around but uh we're going to talk about
very very interesting topics and and
that has to do with Alternatives perhaps
alternatives to the standard Paradigm
and I remember you as a mentor that you
taught me many things uh and one of them
was to not be afraid and to take risks
but take prudent prudent risks and
pursue Avenues even when people didn't
really think they would bear fruit I've
had a lot of people on this podcast who
are very negative about String Theory a
lot of people that are negative about
inflation but I've also had more people
that are positive about those things
including your collaborator Cameron
baffa well I had on many years ago as
well uh and so I want to ask you what is
the most fascinating area of physics
that you're currently researching right
now
so as you know I work on a wide range of
topics all theoretical cosmology
but handicapped because I don't do
computer work
so I have to do work with pencil paper
and most importantly an eraser
because I often
the ideas don't pan out or I make
calculation mistakes but I'm so
cosmology is the area that I'm really
fascinated about because it's an area
that connects deep philosophical
questions with hard data and your group
is one of the groups providing the hard
data
and the philosophical questions they
concern the origin of the universe
and that also means the origin of space
and time
now
um so you mentioned two things you
mentioned string theory and inflation
so
let me Focus personal inflation
so over the past 30 years inflation has
become the Paradigm of early Universe
cosmology in fact it's made it into
astronomy textbooks you read an
astronomy textbook and this section on
cosmology starts with
saying that the Universe began with a
big bang and Then followed the period of
inflation
which is exponentially growing space
like explanatory growing prices
so now
um
there's a sort of a problem with this
scenario
and uh
if you would have asked me three years
ago how I would judge the chance of
inflation being part of the story
I would have said well more than 50 but
it's worthwhile exploring Alternatives
because a theory grows
by being challenged with Alternatives
and if you work out good Alternatives
and then you can basically challenge
people who work on the standard Paradigm
to do better
but Somalia has changed and my view has
changed because of something which we
call the transplanting censorship
conjecture
so the GCC and this is a paper which
bedroya and vafa wrote now almost four
years ago 2019 there was a follow-up
paper which I co-authored within it and
with Mariana Lavelle
so
inflation is the idea that space expands
exponentially
and that means that if we have little
waves on this space
then the wavelength of these little
waves also expands exponentially
so in our models of inflation if we look
at the wavelengths of a small density
perturbations the density perturbations
that your experiments are measuring if
we Trace them back to the whole universe
then in the standard inflationary models
we find that they emerge with a
wavelength which is smaller than the
Planck length
and maybe not all of your
listeners know what the Planck length is
but it is the uh boundary of of our
knowledge we know that on length scale
smaller than the plant growth we don't
understand the physics
so the problem for inflation is that
everything that we measure today
according to an inflationary scenario
starts out in this window where we don't
understand the physics
and uh So based on this argument
brilliant postulated that there's a new
fundamental principle of physics
that says that this situation never
should happen
uh little density perturbations on
length scale smaller than a plant length
should never be able to become larger
than a particular length scale which is
called the Hubble radius
which is the inverse expansion rate and
this is sort of the length scale above
which these little waves if they start
from quantum mechanics they kind of
become classical and we all metal
classical things distribution of
galaxies microwave and esoter piece
so this transplantian sensorship
conjecture says that uh things that are
now classical never come from this
transplanting
is this related to like a cosmic
censorship or a um okay
and so after this initial work I was
asking the question where does this come
from how can we actually argue for this
and I know that Roger Penrose is a
frequent guest on your program that's
right and I guess you were referring to
his Central contractor and so the first
justification that I give
for the transplanting censorship
manufacturer is the an analogy with
penrose's
um conjecture so what Penrose says is
following Penrose notices that
um black holes with small charge
they have singularities in the center
but an observer who's outside of a black
hole never measures anything
that comes from this singular region
so the Observer is protected by a
horizon
now Einstein gravity allows for
Solutions where the charge is bigger
than a mass
and for such black holes with charge
greater than a mass the poor Observer
far away from the black hole is not
protected from The Singularity and so
Penrose postulated that in the theory
that completes generativity
such pathological Solutions cannot arise
so now if we translate Penrose to
cosmology with a very well-defined
translation schema then we get precisely
the transplant in central contraction
um
now there are two other justifications
that I can give for the transplant
incentive conjecture and they are both
associated with Words which are quite
popular these days in the high energy
physics literature
one of them is unitarity and the other
one is
um entanglement entropy
so let me talk about unitary device so
we would like to have a theory in which
we can calculate how things evolve from
the past to the Future
in a well-defined calculation way but
Theory would satisfies that is a unitary
Theory
so the word unitary also comes from
doing it at Quantum level
now you can show that in a model
um
okay in an expanding Universe if we
describe things using what's called
effective field Theory
which is Einstein's classical Theory
coupled to what physicists learn in
graduate school
you you take practice waves you take
matter Fields you expand them
in Warrior modes we need plane waves you
take each pain wave separately when you
view each plane wave as a harmonic
oscillator
so that's effective field Theory yeah if
we try to do that in an expanded
universe then we have to continuously
create new
pain waves
that's non-unitary and if we want to
protect classical observables from this
problem
then we're going to get the
transplanting sensitive conjunction
and the third justification is if we
want the entanglement if you want the
entropy density at the end of inflation
to be smaller than the entropy density
that we need at the beginning of the
standard Big Bang phase of cosmology
then inflation cannot last long and too
long that again gives a transplanted
censorship conjecture
and So based on this transplant in
central conjecture based on these
unitarity and entropy considerations I
will make the provocative claim that the
models of inflation that we have
violate unitarity and value the second
law of thermodynamics
and I pause you for one second remember
because I'm sure people are asking when
I hear unitarity I think back to my
quantum mechanics class with Leon Cooper
or Frank Levin your former colleagues
when you were at Brown
and I think back to interpretations of
quantum mechanics I think back to the
Copenhagen interpretation I I think back
to things that um respectable physicists
should not enter into until much later
in their career are these unitarity
considerations are they in any way
related to an interpretation or do they
have a direct physical
falsifiable observationally motivated uh
a place in in terms of their their
non-interpretive behavior in other words
is it just a matter of interpretation uh
and then we should shut up and calculate
as David merman used to say or are they
real manifestations we can get access to
physically
I claim that there are real
manifestations that we can get access to
them from no relation with these
measurement issues of uh of quantum
mechanics the ones that you alluded to
so now one way you I I can make this
specific is um so I said that if you
want to treat inflation the way
you usually treat it you have to
continuously create new waves yes yes of
different wavelengths now you've given
me a recipe for setting the initial
amplitude of these waves if you create
them
and this choice is going to
perfect observations
so I can give the standard Choice which
is not well Justified but if I give a
modified choice and I will get
completely different results from that
for the spectrum of microorganisms which
you measure so different from the
Harrison zordovic
and different not only in minor ways but
in major ways
interesting that's great based on these
problems
that I changed my mind I actually think
that
alternatives to inflation probably are
more promising at a person's day really
so when I when I've talked with my
friend Paul steinhardt or Neil Turok and
and many others Anna Aegis who's a
brilliant young cosmologist in New York
and also in Germany
um and I I tell them the following uh
kind of complaint from an
experimentalist point of view I love
Alternatives but better than an
alternative would be would be a theory
that doesn't invoke some of the aspects
of inflation in other words it should be
as radically different from inflation in
my humble experimentalist perspective in
other words it shouldn't have a
Multiverse it should not have uh
different runaway chaotic behaviors it
should not have even a scalar field and
yet and yet correct me if I'm wrong
all of these including sir Roger's
conformal cyclic cosmology which I've
talked to him about specifically and and
Aegis and Neil Turk and Paul steinhardt
I've said you all have the same feature
that our good old friend
um sir Fred Hoyle and my late colleague
Jeffrey Burbage and Margaret Burbage had
which was a creation field they called
it the sea field in quasi-study state
cosmology nowadays Paul and Anna they
call it just a scalar field uh Andre
Linde past guest calls it the infoton
field and Sir Roger Penrose calls era
bonds and another phenomena there are
objects that we don't encounter other
than the Higgs boson and so I say to my
theorist friends can you give me a model
that doesn't have a scalar field because
at some level you have to still pause it
where did that darn scalar field come
from in the first place that's right so
I completely agree with what you said in
in everything uh
to even amplify him on what you said
with scalar Fields you can
get any cosmology you want
and so
now
my friend Slava mukanov who's one of the
this foundation work on on inflation how
inflation gives rise to a mechanism of
of forming structure he would agree with
the following statement that I make if
the simplest scalar field model does not
give something interesting so if in your
theoretical model you have to you have
to tweak the scaling field then it is no
longer a good model
but so but now you asked an another
question
so are there models of a universe
cosmology which do not involve scalar
Fields yes and the answer is yes and so
uh I've been working on on I proposed
together with you I guess the
commonwether a model of our Universal
cosmology based on superstring Theory
called string gas cosmology this was
back in 1989 and we have a improved
version of that recently called Matrix
cosmology
so the answer to your question is yes
that I I'm very keen
on working
on cosmological models which do not
involve a scalar field and I'm going to
make a prediction for for your
observations okay and that prediction is
going to be
a consistency relation between the tilt
of the
B mode polarization that you're going to
measure the gravitational wave spectrum
then the tilt of the density
perturbations
and for people who know the nomenclature
it's NT equals 1 minus NS
and this comes from
uh
model based on super string theory
now can I make a side comment of course
okay now I'm
critical to
um about inflation as as you gathered
but I'm actually
uh
I I like
String Theory I think string theory is a
good starting point
to try to understand the universe and I
know that this among many people is an
unpopular opinion anyway so in our
models the world Universe cosmology
indeed we start with super strength
Theory however
we have to start not with a toy model
not with an effective field Theory based
on super strength Theory but with
something truly stringy
all work with commonwether we sort of
said well
what's the difference between a theory
based on strings
and a theory based on point particles
well
every all of your listeners can can see
the difference if you have a string you
can stretch it
and you can't tweak it
blistering can vibrate and if you have a
string on a donut
this string can wrap the
donuts can move on the donut but it
cannot wrap the donut
and they also know
no vibrational modes of a point particle
so
uh commonweather myself we were
asking the question if you start with
um the same
um idea of a background space time
that we usually use in cosmology and
instead of having Point particles on
this space time but instead we have
strings the basic entities being strings
will we get a difference
and we realize that there's a big
difference
and to illustrate this difference is the
following I can do I can say the
following you click a box of strings and
you can press it
you take a box of Point particles then
you compress it
now if you take the box of Point
particles and you can press it to
smaller and smaller and smaller sizes
the temperature becomes higher and
higher and higher without a limit
and eventually as temperature reaches
Infinity yes but you take a box of
strings you compress it initially the
temperature rises but then the
temperature approaches a limiting value
and the
increase in temperature slows down
instead of
um singularity
there's no more Singularity you start
producing the oscillator modes of
strings and if the Box becomes small
enough then all of the energy goes into
Springs that wind the Box whose energy
becomes small when the temperature goes
down to zero
and that's this hexador maybe
um this phase in which the temperature
is close to this maximal temperature
this is um the phase that we call the
hogadon phase it's named after hagadon
who first worked out the uh statistical
mechanics of Coast Springs
these strings are sort of behaving like
degenerate matter or they have a they
have a pick and that's not to say
there's anything wrong with that but
they have a different equation of State
than a shoestring or a particle of dust
uh or even Dark Energy if I'm
understanding it correctly because they
they must behave in a degenerate fashion
such that you cool once you exceed in
the uh approaching from high to low
temperatures because then they cool down
again the network the stream network
which is also another phenomenon so if
I'm wrong correct me but Point particles
uh well as you said uh point you can't
you can interact Point particles but
they don't entangle but if I'm not
mistaken the strings can actually
interact they can entangle they can do
more than they can also scatter but
that's not all they can do correct
that's correct but let me go back to
this equation of state which you
mentioned so the equation of state so if
you just have clumps of matter
cold matter that has zero pressure if
you have the radiation microwave
background radiation has positive
pressure now if you have a gas of
strings what happens is that depending
on the density of the strings
this equation of State changes
it starts out that like radiation
and that becomes something like cold
matter and if it becomes something which
has negative pressure what does negative
wow so that's it actually goes from uh
for this is from my cosmology students
that are studying this right now it goes
from an equation of state of one-third
to an equation of state of zero W equals
zero to an equation of state of less
than minus one-third correct that's why
it goes back equals to minus one third
okay now again in your cosmology class
you so you'll be studying equations
based on Einstein's theory that's right
and then
if you just cut the strings to that you
will still
even when the box is small it will the
Einstein equations will say it will
still expand
you that's right so so the so you take
your box of strings
and although the temperature is
decreasing again the Box will still
decrease
so now there's a second aspect of
strings namely what that makes strings
different from oil particles is the
following what do you actually mean by
position
so how do you measure position
so in uh
neurophysics you take particles and you
see where they land
these fruit particles you look at their
momentum and they land somewhere they
start off a point and that's how you can
determine the position
but now for strengths you actually have
these windings right
and there's actually a second way of
defining position
so if you have a gas of strings you
actually have
two ways of defining position is like a
position in a dual position
and if the Box becomes small if it
becomes small smaller than the strength
scale then any experimentalist will be
using the Dual description of defining
space and in terms of that
space will be growing at and you will
have a balancing cosmology with no
singularity
so you'll start off and what will be the
spatial geometry uh in the three
different phases and this is this is now
so the Achilles you know of our early
work
1989 is that we just postulated that we
would always set space is was going to
be a Taurus neither small Taurus or
large dogs so a nine-dimensional donut
because in string theory you have nine
dimensions of space
now you can ask me why this is not a
problem
this is actually a very nice feature
really it's a very nice feature yes why
is that
okay so this is now a digression
and again
um
so the way that I answered I was I will
give you a defense of string theory
against some of the popular criticisms
and uh one popular criticism is that
with strength you can get anything you
want
you have this landscape
of possibilities
so I'm sure many of you I guess I've
I've actually said that I have to
confess to you as my father in a certain
sense Robert that I have used that
complaint I have used that attack
against none other than one of the
people who founded
um string uh string cosma string uh
field Theory and that's Michio Kaku who
came on for his book last year the god
equation in which he claimed I said to
him well you know Michio I don't have to
he he said well string theory is often
accused of predicting anything as as you
just alluded to
um but uh but that's that's just like
saying in Maxwell's equations you have
to tell me what the what the ground
state is I said but Michio once I tell
you the ground state everything is
determined and furthermore from just the
field strength Maxwell tensor I can get
all the equations of all the behavior of
every dynamical object in space-time at
least in that simplified version whereas
you need to specify it for each one of
these models and furthermore it's it
could change as the landscape and the
swampland conjecture sort of highlight
so anyway I'm just confessing to you
Robert that I have used that attack and
uh but uh but the first person the only
person so far
maybe you'll be the second person but
the only person to say that string
theory makes a prediction that's
experimentally verifiable is your
colleague Cameron and but it wasn't it
wasn't all that satisfying because he
basically said that string theory
predicts the mass of the electron can
vary from you know 10 to the 16th uh
Planck masses uh to tend to the mind you
know to 10 to the minus two Planck
masses so in other words there's a lower
limit and upper limit but
he didn't you're not predicting it to
with Precision that any high school
chemistry you know student would be
satisfied with anyway sorry for the
digression on top of the aggression but
you're right people do criticize string
theory for the the lack the infinitude
of possible ground States essentially
but now let's go back and forget and
fill out the strings and go back to
point particles if we do that
we have we can have any number of
dimensions of space and time no one
tells us why there should be three
dimensions of space yeah four five six
seven eight nine
we can have arbitrary number of fields
we can have one electromagnetic field
true electromagnetic fields three
electromagnetic fields
we have one scalar field two scalar
Fields three scalables we can have any
kind of potential if we want for any of
these scalar fields
and these fields can have any range
so it's a huge swamp land of theories if
we forget about strings
now comes string theory and string
theory says that
we can only string clear is only
consistent in nine plus one dimensions
of space and time so nine dimensions of
space and one dimension so it's
restrictive now
it's
um so I'm I haven't worked out the
detailed connections between string
theory and particle physics models so I
can't tell you at low energy how many
particles string theory predicts but
someone who has good mathematical
talents will eventually be able to to to
tell that so all scalar fields that
emerge from String Theory have a
geometrical origin
their potentials are constrained
so among all possible effective field
theories theories that you can get from
point particles this huge swarm plant
they're only small islands that stick
out habitable Islands
unfortunately it's not just one Island
it's a number of islands and it's a
landscape
so
so you see that this is why I I argue
that the criticism
that string theory predicts anything you
want is misplaced it is not as
predictive as we would like it to be
maybe eventually it will be
but it is a step forward
mm-hmm
interesting so I'm getting a native
prediction for cosmology a specific
prediction which is the one I just told
you right so if we pivot back to
um the you know this notion of of of the
predecessor
um Let me let me explain it like this
maybe they're prerequisites of these
various
um Frameworks for the early Universe
there's sir Roger Penrose conformal
cyclic cosmology which requires these
era bonds and this this strange form of
matter as he calls it that evolves and
changes and then it also emerges from a
a phase of of black hole entropy uh with
cotton formal dynamics that I still
don't fully understand but uh but be
that as it may it involves a scalar
field let's just say it like that or it
involves a new physical manifestation
field
um next there is the uh there is the
creation field the C field of quasi-city
State cosmology
um there is the
scalar field of uh of the of the
bouncing cosmological model of of Paul
steinhardt uh there are um there are
alternatives uh as well that have
scalaria and of course the inflation
inflaton scalar field now I always point
out there's only one scalar field that
we know for sure exists and that's the
Higgs boson but that's a very different
type of field than what the inflaton
would be so I guess the problem that I
have with that is you know who put that
there uh you know uh where did it come
from and so I would ask you the same
thing is the minimum prerequisite for
string gas cosmology just the existence
of space-time I mean all these other
fields have space time plus they have a
scalar field so it would be in Occam's
like simplification to only require
space time am I getting that right
that's right absolutely right so our
input was uh space-time and a gas of
strings but now you see there was a
problem with this scenario because we
don't just want to postulate a
space-time that behaves in some
arbitrary way yes we want to derive how
it evolves
in this holy face
and in this early work of 1989 we had
put it in by hand
so in my opinion that was the okay let's
hear about early work and so in our
recent work we've been trying to
uh improve on this
um
now I I completely share your view that
we should not try to invent new scale of
yields
so we're going to try to do something
different now
at the beginning I was sort of arguing
that if we have
if we want to describe the earlier the
early universities in fields
then we are faced with this problem
potential immunity problem yes so we
shouldn't just be using fields we should
be really using something fundamentally
new
we should be using what physicists in my
field call a non-preservative definition
of string theory so let's step back and
analyze what I mean by that if you go
back to particles then classically we
know what particles do we like on a
billiards table we know how particles
move
particles scatter classically we we can
include Quantum effects in the
scattering of particles
these are the things that uh you do in
accelerate experiments
but if we want to describe the theory of
particles the theory of an arbitrary
number of particles we have to replace
the notion of a particle by a field
like the electromagnetic field yes and
the particle will just be a little
localized excitation of the field
now in string theory we know how strings
evolve classically
and after a lot of work we've also been
able to study the quantum mechanical
scattering of strings
but we don't have a theory of an
arbitrary number of strings the analog
of the field theory of particles but
there is a proposal
and the proposal was made in 1996 1997
by Banks Fishler and saskant it is a
matrix model
and this was our starting point
so now you see I'm not some people who
you've interviewed are radical
they want to do things that are
completely new and actually
um
see if there's a radical I'm actually
fairly conservative I just said well we
need a non-productive definition of
super String Theory what is the best
thing on the market
and so we took that so
do you want me to say a few words about
that yeah absolutely and I want to make
sure we have time to go over some of
your slides at least too okay
good so
we are starting with a theory in which
the basic ingredients are matrices
and there is no space
it is a quantum mechanical model like a
system of spins but yet it's a set of
Matrix so it's a Quantum mechanically
well-defined system the very large
matrices
n by n Matrix is where we let N Go to
Infinity
but we there are no similarities it's a
well-defined matrix model
this time
and what we do is we consider this
matrix model in a high temperature state
now there's no more Evolution there's no
more space no more time no evolution
and our goal was to try to see what we
can get out of this well-defined
starting point
since in our recent work we've we've
been able to get the construction of
emergent time emerging space
earning larger metrics so the metric is
something that gives
describes a distance in space
and an early Universe cosmology out of
that including things that you can
measure
in observations
now the time that emerges out of this
Construction
in the limit where you take the size of
matrices to Infinity this time is
continuous
not just discrete ticks of time but it
is it is a continuous interval like a
string and it ranges from minus symmetry
you can plus infinity
so there's no big bang Singularity the
space that emerges that we have to work
a little bit harder also is continuous
and it is also infinite
so the space automotives is infinite
but it is infinite only in three
dimensions
not in nine dimensions so even though
the theory is the theory of
nine-dimensional
space
and one dimension of time
what emerges is only a three-dimensional
Infinite Space
and the other six dimensions are some
structure which has not even a
well-defined geometrical meaning
okay then we have it
since now that we have space we can we
can give a definition of length
and once we have a differential of
length we have coordinates
we know what the metric is
and what emerges is that this metric is
spatially flat
so we don't get the space that emerges
it's not like the surface of a sphere
or the surface of Saddle like it is just
flat it is something that evolves in
time when the space is flat
okay so we don't need inflation to
produce an inference Universe we don't
need inflation to produce something
that's flat
the problems which inflation was
initially designed to cure or
automatically cured in this approach and
there are no scales in this approach
so there'd be no deviation from the
Harrison's aldovic ah now comes the
fluctuations since we have a thermal
stake we have thermal fluctuations
so we can compute the
um
the perturbations
and we find that we get something that
is roughly consistent with observations
we get
the first ordering the approximation we
get what you just called the Harrison's
a little bit Spectrum something that's
scaling that
so if you take a box and you look at
fluctuations in in a fixed uh box
then independent of spatial scale you
get the same magnitude of fluctuations
that's scaling out
so the first approximation we get that
and if we now go back to our string gas
cosmology toy model then we
automatically get the tilt
get the deviation and we get this
consistency relation which I gave you we
also get gravitational waves
and there's no cosmological constant
hmm
so this is something I'm really excited
about
and obviously this is a beginning of a
research program and but I think I've
answered your program this is an attempt
to obtain a neural Universe cosmology
which does not involve scalar fields
your criticism against these various
other approaches which involve scale of
fields I think they're very interesting
in fact I think if you like bouncing
cosmologies I think you have to pay
close attention to the to this uh egg
periodic scenario which was initially
proposed by Curry oval steinhardt and
Turok because among bouncing models
that's the most promising
in my opinion yes and that's one of my
that was one of my questions from uh our
friend Stefan Alexander your former
graduate student who's gone on to become
uh become a professor at our very own uh
my very own alma mater uh also add some
questions from uh from my colleague Amit
yadav who is working as a scientist for
me for many many years
um uh and maybe while I'm getting those
up uh then we could get the slides that
you have we've actually covered a lot of
the slides but I want to get this slide
if you could put up your slide slide 17
because this is a terrifying slide to me
this is terrifying to me you did mention
there are gravitational waves you did
mention there'd be a consistency
relationship between the gravitational
wave power Spectrum the the stilt of
What's called the tensor power Spectrum
for the aficionados out there N Sub T
and the relationship between N Sub T and
you see this slide is in the context of
inflation
it is saying that if you try to
construct an inflationary model which is
consistent with a transplunk in
censorship conjecture then you need low
scale inflation and then you get these
negligible primordial gravitational
waves yes yeah now you see since I think
that this is not the way to go because
of all these problems you should not be
scared about that but if you hear people
say that
um that a large R is a Smoking Gun of
inflation that's where you should inject
a large R is not at all the Smoking Gun
signal of inflation it's an alternative
inflation typically produce a fairly
large r
well not not the Alternatives of
conformal cyclic cosmology are better
maybe not that one that would have not
haven't studied but
um in all realization of the of Paul
sinus equirotic scenario we get a fairly
large valuable
and it's I guess cosmology as well
and we get a rough consistency relation
which I can tell you privately which
gives us a magnitude of R but it's only
a rough so I prefer not to mention but
maybe you need you see
since this is bad news for standard
models of inflation let me go to another
slide
and namely the criteria so if your
Advent of young
person for example a young listener to
this show
and you want to construct your own model
of the old universe
then what I'm going to give you is the
the criteria which you have to satisfy
so first of all this is the data that
you need to reproduce so here the
horizontal axis is angular scale large
angle scales small angular scales on the
right
and the vertical axis is amount of
structure amount of an esoter piece
and
the black dots or the data and it is the
data that you have to fit
and this is actually old data now the
error bars are smaller
and this is your red Theory kind of
which is not important this context
now
the red Theory curve was actually
predicted 10 years before inflation
and people send you and this is a graph
which I took from the zeldovic sunyai of
paper of 1970.
so here
the horizontal axis is space and the
coordinates that I'm using are
coordinates which are expanding uh
spaces expanding and the vertical axis
is time and this time here is the time
when the microwave background is
released
now
if
assumed that there's some unknown
mechanism that produces
waves of density density waves at very
early times on all wavelengths with a
scale event spectral
now it is a fact that these waves are
frozen in
they are standing waves until the
wavelength becomes equal to this length
this diagonal curve which is actually
the
standard Big Bang Horizon and then they
start to oscillate
so the wave that you catch here
that enters the acrosses The Horizon
will add recombination you catch it
stand as a standing wave with maximum
amplitude
but this wave we're tested on five
quarters of an oscillation you catch it
at a minimum so it is this
evolution of density waves
which explains these features
so this the physics that gives rise to
this was well understood 10 years before
inflation but you do need a mechanism
that produces these initial waves and so
these are the three criteria for
successful early Universe cosmology
first of all
The Horizon
which is a distance that light can
travel from the beginning has to be much
larger than
what we think it is in standard Big
Brand cosmology because we have to
produce a roughly isotropic universe
and then
these you have to have a mechanism that
generates fluctuations
and in order for this mechanism to be
described by causal physics physics
abandon Einstein's loss of special
activity then the length scale that you
produce a fluctuations on has to be
smaller than the Double Radius at Somali
time
this is second
Criterion the third Criterion is this
game about
and so inflation satisfies these three
criteria
so time
space physical length
uh this is a period of inflation with
space expands explanatory the arise
expands exponentially becomes
exponentially larger than the hopper
radius wavelengths of
fluctuations grow exponentially and so
if we Trace back the waves that you are
measuring Brian you trace them back they
start out inside the harbor radius
so here you have the two first criteria
satisfied but if you take a balancing
cosmology so this is Bounce Point
expanding phase contraction phase no
inflation this is what the wavelength of
the scales do
so time runs from minus infinity to plus
infinity plus causality or wall of space
fluctuations start out smaller than
Arbor radius you have the possibility of
a causal mechanism and in our spring gas
scenario we basically have something
that looks like quasi-static and it gets
rise to your space time diagram that
looks something like this but now let me
give you give the challenge to the young
people
the the young people who want to work in
this field who were maybe not even
undergraduates yet you have to come up
with something better than the three
things which I just briefly showed you
would satisfies these three criteria
and Brian you don't have to be afraid at
all about this previous slide number 17.
okay
good to know I'll be able to rest easier
because uh I'm actually not afraid of it
uh let me take a detour because that's
what I love to do with you
um so I think that most things in
cosmology uh do not have a natural scale
in other words as you show in uh you
know many times
inflation could occur it could have
occurred at a very low energy scale it
could have occurred in a very high
energy scale we actually don't know
there's no lower limit on the energy
scale of inflation on the other hand
there is a lower limit on the amount of
B mode polarization in other words there
is an amount of B mode polarization
that's not necessarily primordial and
you hinted at it on a slide but my
colleague here Rafael flaugher who you
know undoubtedly very well is one of the
Stephen weinberg's final students
um Rafael and David spurgle and others
have have looked at this Paul steinhardt
as well and and this is that because of
the what are called secondary
perturbations there is a lower limit and
I think my experimental colleagues uh
you you have a lot of affection and
appreciation and you always did for
people like Peter timbe my advisor and
so forth and and you were always very
connected to experiment but sometimes I
think you give experimentalists a little
bit too much credit and praise uh
because there is a sense of dishonesty I
believe that we are attempting to
measure certain things with very big
projects some of which I am very
intimately involved with as you know the
Simon's Observatory the Simon's array
bicep in the past Etc and that is that
we're basically assuming the conclusion
that inflation took place because
there's a preponderance of cosmologists
that do support it uh and uh and
furthermore it is amenable it has a
certain pleasing nature to it it even
leads to to things like the Multiverse
and other things that some people find
pleasurable others find distasteful uh
both uh to cosmology but even to the
scientific method we'll leave that aside
yeah so in terms of inflation predicting
a Multiverse
I would argue that this is not the case
my friends would would agree with that
and let me
maybe uh quote something from one of the
other guests
uh Sabina hasenville
um she said sometimes people take their
equations too seriously
and don't think about the physics
and I think this
argument that inflation predicts a
Multiverse where you treat inflation
just in terms of your scalar field this
is uh
treating your equations in a domain
where you can't trust them
so similarly yes I I agree in fact
people talk about things like the Planck
length as being some fundamental
building block scale of nature in
reality uh if that were true then the
Planck Mass would also have to have some
fundamental significance but the Planck
mass is about the mass of an egg of a
fly it's actually a very large mass uh
not to say the plank length is is large
of course it's very small but there's
nothing fundamental about it so people
take that very seriously Elon Musk
recently said that you know that
basically the existence of the Planck
scale sets an absolute limit on the
number of digits of pi which I found
ridiculous and uh but you know he's a
he's an amateur physicist I hope to have
him on the podcast at some point but but
getting back to my conjecture if
physicists were honest uh my my let me
just say if I was honest because I'm not
gonna impede on the reputations of my
colleagues and friends but I was honest
I would say that Jim Simons or the
National Science Foundation I'd say look
we actually have no idea what would
happen
um if inflation has an energy scale
that's that's even detectable but we
know for sure that there must be a
fluctuation of b-mode fluctuations at a
scale corresponding to 10 to the minus
6. a tensor to scalar ratio of 10 to the
minus 6. from what are called secondary
perturbations you can explain this much
better than I can but Robert that's also
uh that that is interesting to an
experimentalist we love lower limits so
there's a lower limit on the mass of the
neutrinos
that provides a very tantalizing Target
that we can then optimize experiments
such as the Simon's Observatory
to end the CMB stage four project we can
optimize those to detect that lower
limit as a worst case scenario but for
inflation or the lack thereof
the lower limit comes from the secondary
perturbations now if we don't see those
secondary perturbations I claim that
would be interesting also because that
would mean there's something wrong with
general relativity in a very yeah so I
think but we know that to detect such
perturbations is way beyond the reach of
maybe a thousand Simon's observatories
in other words a trillion dollar Mission
would not be sufficient to detect a
threshold of 10 to the minus 6 at more
than you know zero Sigma essentially so
I claim my I I'll just say me because I
don't impugn any of your friends or my
friends
that we're not being honest because
we're we're pitching this experiment as
the definitive way to ratify justify
detect or falsify inflation when it
really can't do that and uh ultimately
we should be saying let's measure 10 to
the minus 6 except we want to do it in
our lifetimes and I think that's a sign
of me being greedy uh who's to say that
you know Penzeys and Wilson wanted to
measure emote polarization with their
first instrument 1965. that would have
been impossible too so there's no
guarantee that nature will cooperate on
a time scale of your technology so I
guess this is all a way of saying that
experimentalists should not be
praised too much because a lot of times
we want to get the job done for our
careers and for our you know for our own
intellectual curiosity while we're alive
but it may not be possible and so for
that that's sort of my rant about
experimentalists and and not and not
putting them on too much of a pedestal
yes I agree with this wrong
advertisement of the goal of certain
experiments so I completely agree with
everything that you said yeah but I
think they make very good specifications
exactly for the kind of uh
um experiments that you're working on
one of them is we you can if you manage
to find the ABI mode a cosmological
prime module be more background used to
go after the Tilt yes
because uh this tilt relation which I
gave you is something that string theory
first predicted
and so if if you find such a tilt that
that would be great news but they're
also much more modest things and you can
do
and maybe I can now turn to some of the
other yeah I don't only work on early
Universe cosmology yes I have a pet I
have several pet topics with one pet
topic are cosmic strings yes you
actually tasked me with a project to do
that when I was considering in a in a
crisis state which I think all graduate
students must go through at one point or
another where we totally question what
we're doing Robert now I'll get your
advice to to young people at the very
end of the podcast but
um I had a crisis of confidence I wasn't
sure I really wanted to be an
experimentalist Mark kaminkowski
recently called me a closet theorist
anyway but I did a project with you and
you assigned me cosmic strings and it
was about the deficit angle that they
would induce and what to have a
polarization and I never came even close
to solving it and I apologize you know
mayor culpa later on we moved to what
you know to Wisconsin but um but tell me
tell me about these cosmic strings why
are they so mercurially why are you so
interested in this is 30 years I've
known you why do they still fixate you
so delightfully so right so there's nice
physics but there's also a good
motivation and that motivation comes
from particle physics
so we know that the standard model of
particle physics is incomplete
because we've measured neutrino masses
and raise dark matter and the dark
matter doesn't fit into the stand model
now
um with accelerate experiments you can't
really probe
things beyond the standard model like
energy scales it's beyond the standard
model very high
but with cosmology you have the chance
yes so now I would divide particle
physics models which go beyond the
standard model I would divide them into
four categories
and let's make the analogy with
different kinds of metals
so if you take a metal in the fluid
State and you call it then certain
method Metals will lead to defects
like in Crystal effects some metals will
have no defects
other metals will have point-like
defects another class of metals will
have line defects
and a fourth class will have planar
defects and it's similar
in terms of standard in terms of
particle physics models some particle
physics models predict defects which are
planar those are already brought up by
cosmology
then others predict defects which are
linear
and those are very interesting signal
signatures in cosmology and they are
constrainable and therefore they are
very they are fun to work on and also
interesting because if you could find a
signal of a cosmic string in the sky you
would have then shown that the way
beyond the standard model of particle
physics is in this one class
of the four
the bottom line is that there's good
motivation to
um look uh or to look for the signatures
of cosmic strings in the sky now cosmic
strings produce
signatures in microwave Sky they produce
lines in the sky across Workshop
temperature jumps and they produce
rectangles in the sky where there is
extra polarization
with a
uniform Direction
and your linearly increasing magnitude
and that includes remote polarization
[Music]
so
you could
go after this
and you could ask the question
um
if you have a map
of polarization with a particular
accuracy how
severely can you constrain particle
physics models which have Cosmic
strengths there's one free provider in
those models and this is a tension of
the strings
the tension is already constrained
because we haven't seen in temperature
maps of the microwave background we
haven't seen these jumps
so there are things like that that you
can there's there's good motivation
for looking at the micro sky in
polarization independent of inflation
[Music]
so uh and there are of course many many
others and I I did not mean in any way
to impugn the kind of deep passion that
all of my colleagues find as I said the
neutrino mass is amenable to Cosmic
microwave background polarization
measurements let me ask you what um
parenthetically Robert
uh if we measure with the Simon's
Observatory or maybe with the dark
energy surveys or bearing on acoustic
survey some combination of cosmological
experiments they measure for the very
first time in human history the mass of
an elementary particle such as the
neutrino will your fellow particle
physics theorist will they believe us
oh
can I pass on that
because this is a very good question
um
and you are you ask me to comment on
what other people will say and I simply
don't
I don't have a good feeling I
I don't know
but I'm I'm controversial comments about
other things but but about this I would
like to pass okay good very good that's
that's totally within your right so when
uh to be to be fair to my uh audience
members who are the brightest in the
known universe they will say things like
well uh what what else gives us Credence
in string theory I I agree I often joke
and you know it's hard to do this in
front of you but I often say you know
like quantum computers are very good at
figuring out what quantum computers can
do as as Feynman said you know they'd be
very good at you know calculating a
lagrangian but I don't know about you
Robert but you know when I'm trying to
board an airplane I don't need my iPhone
to diagonalize a hamiltonian uh you know
so that's not practical so practical
similarly I feel like string theory in
the mathematics associated with it is
very very Advanced it's very very much
uh you know in the spirit of being
useful to string theory itself and I
wonder you know to my audience members
who are wanting me to ask you well what
does string theory predict what is the
the resolution of of you know swampland
how how do you reconcile this this
theory that pass guest Eric Weinstein as
very good friend of Stefan Alexander in
mine
has said that it's really devastated the
careers of numerous uh young people
because it kind of was a cartel for a
long time in his mind uh but he's not
here to defend himself or even advocate
for what he believes but but there's
sort of a program that came from Maddie
cyberg and Ed Whitton and others that
established a paradigm for the field
over the last 30 or 40 years and uh and
it hasn't really borne fruit and in fact
past guests Jim Gates uh has been on the
podcast many times similarly super
symmetry these are things that no longer
they were very promising because of the
beauty Elegance simplicity
but do they have to connect to empirical
verification what do you say to them
right so here um uh I'll make a great
defense for string theory
so
first of all I'm convinced that gravity
has to be treated
Quantum mechanically
and you can do
um get Duncan experiments
little you can imagine little
experiments where
uh you can show that you get the wrong
result if you try to treat gravity
classically
and you keep a matter description of uh
that's your kind of description of that
so maybe
um
I don't want to I don't have a slide
illustrating that but
so
now
and I can I just ask you is that true
also in black holes because I've I've
had this debate with sir Roger and I've
said there's no you know there's no
letter from God that says that we you
know have this unification first of all
we don't even have if I'm wrong correct
me but we don't even have a grand
unified theory that's self-consistent
and I always joke we're putting the gut
in front of the toe or the toe in front
of the gut and uh we're now seeking a
Theory of Everything which would include
quantum gravity and subsume it but we
don't even know how to unify the other
forces so it's like uh you know get the
get the dust particle out of your eye so
anyway how do you react to that I mean
why why do you say
so I would
argue that we need to quantize gravity
so now let's
um
let me make an an another argument for
that let's take a point particle a point
particle will uh
have it has a particular mass and
um
it um
it creates a gravitational force field
now you make the mass Higher and Higher
and eventually the
extent of the particle becomes smaller
than
the schwartial radius and the server
instead of having a particle you have a
black hole
so
so if you treat
um
matter Quantum mechanically you have to
treat gravity Quantum mechanically
so that's the starting point so now
I would love if there were
different candidates to do this
but I view String Theory as the most
promising way to quantize matter and
gravity gravity in a unified way
now I said early on that we don't know
how to do it in full generality we don't
have what I earlier called the
non-preterative string theory
but I think that there are two aspects
of a theory that is needed if you want
to describe the Earl universe and also
uh physics are very high energy scales
and this is
um
we need both
quantum gravity and we need to we need
unification and a quantization of
gravity hmm
so then um so again I'm not a string
viewers yeah so I look around what what
is there in the market and uh string
theory is promising one of the reasons
why string theory is promising is that
there are no singularities associated
with
uh
those singularities are the same type
that they offer Point particles
if you start to point particles and you
do a
calculation which is the next to
simplest one
then you find that the probability that
point particles scatter is
infinitely
and then you have to do something called
renormalization that's right to get rid
of this Infinity
so now I was very fortunate to have
taken Quantum field Theory
from a very good lecturer Cindy Coleman
but I was more fortunate that there was
a famous mathematician the different
router Raul bot yeah who was taking the
class
not just occasionally she would come to
every class he would sit in the front
row every time take careful notes and he
would ask all the
uh questions that we students were too
embarrassed to ask
so this made the class really well
really good and there was one point
where ralbot became a little bit uh not
so polite and this is when Sydney
Coleman introduced the concept of
renalization and then he laughed out is
this what you physicists do and he
continued notes but it was absolutely
clear to me that there was no way in
which robot accepted
this reorganization
now this minorization happens not to
matter if you do experiments at Sun it
works fine right which gravity is
involved you simply cannot throw away
these infinitives
that's the cosmological constant problem
and is this well yeah I should point out
that Raul is uh is credited as being the
thesis advisor for Eric Weinstein uh
although Eric says he did not have he
was not his uh well in in Prince in
practice he was not his advisor but I'll
let Eric respond at some other point to
that but uh so yes it is true I mean uh
Feynman accepted reading normalization
but he did in in the electromagnetic
context but he did not accept it in a
string theoretic concept uh of course by
the time he died the cosmological
constant problem really wasn't known in
1988 when he uh unfortunately passed
away
um but uh he did mention yeah you know
this this unification and I guess you
know just again to push back with the
respect so I did have on uh Shelly
glashau three years ago two or three
years ago and we talked about you know
his su5 and uh I I always say that you
know we're kind of uh we're kind of LED
along the path that financial advisors a
financial advisors tell us we should not
oops sorry my computer assistant is is
now pinging me but uh that's okay
um financial advisors will tell you that
past performance is no guarantee of
future results and I think sometimes
there is so much success in the realm of
unification and and symmetry uh and so
forth that it became almost an
expectation that the successor Theory to
provide quantum gravity would be in
those in those same vein as as you know
Shelley tried to do
um after the success of the lecture week
Theory with Weinberg and and
um uh and um why am I blanking on uh
their third colleagues uh and abdisalam
uh so they were very successful but not
a successful looking at uh looking at
you know a concept like su-5
and I know this is not you know again
it's not something you specialize in but
uh do you think we really need more of
that kind of you know the more research
along this this realm will will provide
and bear fruit or is it really going to
take one of the young people that's as
you say maybe listening to this in in
high school or in our own freshman in
college
some new ideas uh that we have become
you know kind of uh over beholden to
what got us here but it's not going to
keep going along the path that we need
to travel
yes I
foreign
approach if we want to understand the
variable universe and if we want to
develop a theory which which is also
true at the highest Energies
smallest length scales
now do we have the tools right now to
make detailed predictions especially for
particle physics and there the answer is
no we need new insights
and uh I think we need we might need a
completely new approach
through strings you're in but I think
this new approach will not go back to
point particles
it will have something
that looks like strings in it
is this related to The Matrix Theory
cosmology yeah this is related can you
go ahead to slides
um to slide 53 please
or 52 please and then share that yeah
continue to show that so
um
in Matrix Theory cosmology again I'm
just a simple humble experimentalist
that you remember uh you know breaking
things on the roof of Barrison Holly but
the uh the notion of emergence comes up
a lot
what does it mean that time emerges in
Matrix Theory Cosmo what is that what
does emergency even mean
so for me it's a construction
it is uh so maybe I should go back a
little bit okay and I know that um
Neil truck when he was on your show he
showed a technical slide so I will now
show a technical slide as well you get
one per episode Robert one and so he
showed this slide his slide and yeah of
course arguing that this was very
elegant but there were a lot of symbols
here so now what I'm showing you here
this quantity called l
this is uh the model this is all that's
contained in the model and these extra
Guys these are these matrices
and here there is um something that
contains a Time derivative so here in
this model there isn't an initial time
but we take this quantum mechanical
model in the finer temperature state so
we didn't have to construct the new
a new a new time
Okay so
out of these matrices we have to build
something that acts like a Time
that's what a merger means to me
so it's it's a mathematical it's a it's
a kinematic emergence it's it's not to
be taken like in other words Hawking in
in his work would talk and hartle would
talk about imaginary time and then the
imaginary time would sort of cleave off
from the from being complex into being
real that's right he is a trick but he
called it a trick in the book If you
read it is this a trick or is it real
I think it's a trick okay so if he
called it a trick in the book I agree
with that statement good very good so
so
okay so everything comes out of these
matrices now if you look at the details
of these matrices there's something
hidden and what that's hidden
in this d sub Jesus hitting the fact
that there's another Matrix
so there's actually 10 matrices 10
dimensions of space-time yes and I'm is
associated with this Matrix here
um and let me digress a little bit
technically these are
permission matrices so we can diagnose
one of them we'd organize this the
diagonal elements of time
so see the these this Matrix gives us
time and these x i matrices give us
space
in a way that we make precise
so your um treatment your country of
origin was of course uh Switzerland
uh and this gentleman uh here attended
an institution there called eth it's
Albert Einstein for those that are only
listening there are many many listeners
out there
uh and the into the impossible landscape
and he was influenced by Lawrence and
and others who Lorenz I believe said
that you know time and space are
illusory and they're doomed you know in
in a certain sense and again it's one of
these kind of you know slogans that I
never really understood and what does
that mean that space time is doomed does
it mean that like in the future we'll
think I I can't even think about it
because we've always thought about I
mean maybe in the past we thought well
this magnet is different than an
electric you know field but now I I mean
I don't think the average person thinks
oh when I see a magnet that's just a
manifestation of U1 gauge Symmetry and
it's actually the same thing as an
electric no they they think of it as a
magnetic field deflexic compass and puts
something on my refrigerator that my kid
Drew an electric field is you know
responsible for charging my Tesla but
um what does it mean that here to four
space time are doomed and so forth what
was the rents talking about and why did
Einstein your country why did he what
did he make of it
okay so if you take flat space
no matter
then there's still space and time
coordinates yes
but they don't mean anything physically
because there's nothing to measure
anything there's badly to measure
anything right it's empty it's empty
right right now
now let's take
um cosmology let's take a universe which
is the same everywhere which is
homogeneous and isotropic but it is
filled with the microwave background
so now you can measure the temperature
of the microwave background
and we can use that as a clock yes
so
Lawrence was not considering it he was
considering
empty space time
so I think that as coordinates the
coordinates x and t which physics often
use they have no well-defined physical
meaning but as soon as you have matter
in the system then you have then you can
Define physically well-defined
well-defined block variables these are
relational
relational time
there's the part of the Matrix which is
uh homogeneous as a part which is
fluctuating so this so there is matter
in Plus emergent space and time
so the the time coordinate can actually
measure something so this is emergent
time with a physical meaning ah
very good well you've done it again
because uh you're one of the best
Educators that I've ever met Robert and
I often try to ape and and mimic you but
I do a poor poor job but but one thing I
I'm curious about when you teach
cosmology now this is some an ethical
dilemma that I struggle with do I teach
them about positive curvature universes
negative curvature universes when I know
from my colleague my late great mentor
Andrew Lang and and of course my current
friends the uh Lyman page and others who
are very much mentors to me that the
universe is flat
and the spatial curvature is flat and
it's flat as far back as we can really
constrain it but it's so mathematically
entertaining to talk about a positive
space time and I remember you teaching
it to me the only cosmology class I ever
took was by you I audited it as uh as a
graduate student I don't even think I
finished it but but the point being it
had such an impact upon me I remember
you teaching us about it but that was in
1996 uh three years before Boomerang
Maxima and the Toko experiment so Robert
as a professional you know dishing
dishing back and forth do you teach your
students about positive curvature
universes or do you just skip it all
together
no I do okay
observationally we don't know that the
universe is absolutely spatially flat we
just know that the spatial curvature is
very very small yes
the microwave
um experiments have have given the
bounds that's right we don't know
whether pump scale is much larger than
the visible Universe whether whether
space continues to be to be flat so yes
you teach okay I do include spatial
coverage okay so that part of my course
has not changed okay very good
um was there more that you wanted to say
about that what is it a hoof limit what
does that refer to I'm hoping to have
Gerard on the podcast at some point I've
communicated through Lenny suskin uh
once before but tell me what does that
mean the two of the moment so you see
that in this uh
in this model this in this capital l
there are two free parameters this is G
which is like a coupling constant like
uh like the coupling concept actually
having electromagnetism and then there's
a capital N which is a matrix and so the
12th limit simply means that you take
this limit when n goes to Infinity
adjusting this coupling such that this
the G squared times n remains fixed I
see okay very good
um was there more that you wanted to say
about these slides um before we come to
the conclusions of both the episode and
uh the presentation
no I think you should decide where you
want the discussion to head well I I
guess I would like to talk about uh to
take a step back before we get any more
deep into the weeds of cosmology which I
could talk about all day and that's to
talk about
um kind of the uh the the things that
you're passionate about as a scientist
and as an educator again I think of you
as an educator
both of my best friends Stefan and me
personally and many many other students
and also bringing through Brown
University
many people who would go on to be my
mentor like Alexander paulnerv who is a
student of yaakov zeldovic and so it
connected me to these greats of of
history and I want to express my
gratitude to you but also to express
that I utilize advice that you give we
have a lot of young people mostly men
but I'm gratified to say there's a lot
of young women I'm hoping you know your
daughter will listen my daughters will
listen at some point not to this podcast
they're very brilliant uh but uh but I
have a lot of uh a lot of young people
that listen and some are academicians
like us I want to ask you you once told
me a very very Sage piece of advice you
said before you move institutions you
said Brian you're going to move
institutions many times and you were
right you were 100 right I went from
brown to Wisconsin Wisconsin to Stanford
Stanford to Caltech ultimately I went
east to west and then I went north to
south and now I'm in San Diego I told my
wife next stop is the Tijuana Institute
of Technology uh and and so forth um and
I've been to Antarctica multiple times
yeah so you're right I'm going to move
many terms and you said at each place
you go write a paper and keep it in your
drawer this is back when we we used to
use drawers and do you remember telling
me this Robert and you said
um have that paper because when you get
to a new institution you're going to
want to have their Masthead you're going
to want to have their because they're
now your boss Brian you said to me and
they're going to want something for
their return on investment and I thought
uh you know maybe that's true but all
that matters is me it's just my career
so no it's not true it actually the the
profession of being a professor at least
hasn't hasn't changed and it's very
important to give attribution and to
attribute to the place that you're at I
want to ask you Robert how how is being
a professor evolved since you started 30
years ago and and how would you do it
again would you would you enter in into
this this field again
as a professor
right so
I think as a young person
who's debating whether to
um
start graduate school
then I would ask them do they well I
would ask you do you want
to go for curry as a teacher
or a career in business
a nine-to-five job where you have to
dress up in suit and tie not just this
uh jacket that I have suit and client
um or do you want a job a job where you
where you can think about things you can
teach you have a very amount of teaching
obligations but you have quite a bit of
Independence and free time and security
maybe you don't have the highest salary
right so this is a basic choice and and
then
um
you see that I don't give the student at
the
possibility say I want to be a research
professor at Caltech
that's completely unrealistic right so
if you make up if you say I want to go
to the teaching track then yes you
should study uh first of all you should
study what you are interested in
but within the general area that you're
interested in you should study uh you
you should pick a promising area
and for me a promising area is an area
in which the Deep questions and data
and there's there can be the balance
between deep questions and data that can
vary and what I mean data it's not data
that's already there but it's data it's
going to come in
now when I started in cosmology I mean I
got into cosmology by pure accident
there was essentially no data and uh
there were deep questions
and in the intervening time there's been
lots of data
but they give questions have remained
so you know what about the data I see
new observational Windows popping up for
example 21 centimeter cosmology
so right now if if
um a graduate student wants to work with
you know cosmology then I would say it
is still promising because there are
still the Deep questions and there's
still data
but I think we this is a
a question that has to be Revisited
every decade
and it does change it does
there areas which have become their
fields of physics which have become
stale
the basic questions have been addressed
and they'll also only details that have
to be worked out
one thing that's always typified you to
me is your intellectual
peripatetism that you are not an
experimentalist but you are conversant
with the potential of Any Given
experiment uh you are
um as as I say to my students I kind of
reverse what you would say to me and I
say my experimental students
you don't have to do Theory but you have
to know theory in other words you don't
have to come up with an original Theory
or model like an experiment like a
theoretical graduate student might have
to or maybe not who knows what they do
over there nowadays but you should at
least be conversionate what is the
minimum
um that a theorist should know about
experiment a young person
you know this is a question
that I should ask you
you should ask me the other question
namely what what is uh
what amount of theory should a young
experimentalist know
right I guess I feel that I am going to
be advising experimental students and
you're going to be advising theoretical
students so um right but see what I try
so back to your question I with my
students I try to have them follow
what's happening in experimental
cosmology
so we have a joint uh genre Club between
experimental and theoretical cosmology
so I don't know if I'm doing enough and
if I'm doing the right thing but this is
uh what I'm what I'm trying to do and
you know that I try to do that at Brown
you did yeah and I'm I'm trying to do it
at McGill as well in fact we have a very
strong group here Miguel on the
experimental cosmology side very many of
my them are my colleagues on Simon's
Observatory Simon's array and other
projects
um so in in that same vein uh here at UC
San Diego I am the associate director of
the Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination
and Sir Arthur C Clarke had many many
aphorisms and quips and I like to run
them by you and get your response to
them and sort of a final session before
we wrap up when it gets too late uh
where you're uh it's getting very late
and close to evening there uh but I want
to start with his first
and maybe his best known aphorism which
is the following any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic
I want to invert that and ask you the
following question Robert
if you're in how to communicate to an
alien civilization and they're going to
come and devour the Earth unless Robert
brandenberger tells them no don't do it
because we have created the following
Magic
what would that be would it be a
technology would it be a theoretical
Discovery would it be something you did
uh what aspect of humanity
is sort of the most impressive to you as
an Insider but talking to an outsider
actually you know physics is not the
only thing I think you ask some of your
guests also about questions
um outside of physics
I would actually say that it is uh all
of the art that we have produced
for example classical music which I
really like yes and it's all the
literature
and I actually view science as uh
as in part art
so my pencil and paper scientific work I
think I'm obliged to
sell it a bit as art because our
universities are publicly funded
and we need to
we need to give back something
so for me it says very very important to
give back
but uh so
would I so I would include Einstein's
equations
into my list of cultural things that
that I would try
um
to use to persuade the aliens not to
destroy Humanity
now I'm sure and you're capable voice
and and mind it would be a a slam dunk
that they should keep us Keep Us Alive
at least for the entertainment
um
another saying and by the way I do agree
with you 100 because my my late great
colleague here in San Diego Hans Parr
who was a student of Leon Letterman's at
Cal at Columbia he used to say that
relativity gr was the culmination of
Western Civilization what are you
talking about you know have you have you
ever seen the Sistine Chapel or you know
have you have you ever you know heard a
Bach Fugue he said no no because to make
relativity uh it required the the work
of thousands of people in different
cultures and different nationalities in
different locations throughout space and
time uh language and and deeply
influential poetry and and so forth so I
agree with you and and I agree with my
late colleague Hans I miss him
tremendously but but it is overlooked
because we often think that the main
purpose of science is to produce
technology and I didn't hear any
technology in your talk today and I
think that's perfectly acceptable
because that that's what makes us
uniquely human you don't look at a baby
and say oh what technology can it
produce okay so I I I'm very very much
appreciated what you said and I do
believe it will work to prevent our
devouring uh by aliens okay next
question
uh is uh it involves Arthur C Clarke's
famous movie the 2001 A Space Odyssey
and there are these monoliths uh I don't
know if you've ever seen it but there
are these monoliths these kind of we
don't know what they are
could be a time capsule it could be a
warning it could be something ominous it
could be something benign we don't
really know but I like to think of it as
sort of a sort of a last will and
testament and I want to ask you uh in in
Judaism we have a concept called the
ethical will a Zava ah and the Zaba ah
is what you want to be queef in terms of
wisdom maybe knowledge but mostly wisdom
and not monetary
so I want to ask you if you were to
write an ethical will for when you
depart the Mortal coil in a hunt at age
120 please uh no sooner uh what would
you put in an ethical will to give as
wisdom to generations of not just your
biological errors but your ideological
errors that I am lucky enough to
consider myself a part of
okay I will answer that question from a
point of view of a teacher in particular
from the point of view of a student
advisor
and the
message would be that every person has
their own strengths
and it's you should build on this on the
strengths
and at the same time
try to induce the person to work on
their weaknesses
very good this is something that can be
applied in in all areas I think and I
think it's it's appropriate for you as a
teacher because as I said when you told
me this thing I remember it 30 years
later so it's obviously very meaningful
to me about uh you know kind of the
obligations we have as employees to our
employers and to the the pursuit of
Science in a grand tradition but I also
have scaled that up that I teach it to
my students you know who are like your
grand students or your grand advisees in
some sense uh and uh and so it scales
and and your lessons live on and they
already are influencing people
ideologically so I thank you for that
Robert okay uh we're almost done yeah
um
so maybe this is a message to to the
students who are listening
so this treating
um your fellow students
uh realizing that they all have their
strengths
that that's important also for students
when I while I was at Brown I actually
saw students discriminating against
students other students just because
um they had different color of the skin
and because they had a different
scientific background yeah
and uh I remember you were known for
having students from as far away as
Brazil and as close as New York and
Trinidad and and it's quite remarkable
and it and but it never
um it wasn't noteworthy to me if for
some reason I I just thought that was
natural of you and that I didn't think
oh Robert's going out of his way to
Mentor an African-American or a
Brazilian or someone from uh the former
Soviet Bloc countries I just felt that's
that's just Robert but now I see it is
unfortunately I've seen uh very
different things happening yeah
so I think you're right
um so uh but let me let me ask you one
more two more questions if you'll uh
pardon and have your patented
forbearance and Indulgence of me Robert
and uh the first one is another quote by
Sir Arthur well I'll I'll give you a
bonus quote so one of his favorite
quotes of mine at least of his that I
like is he says that for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert uh
I won't ask you to comment on that but I
I do use that on occasion when my
department chair gets out of hand uh but
I will now pivot to two of his final uh
comments
and the first one is this
when an elderly but distinguished
scientist says something is possible he
is very much likely to be correct or she
but when he or she says something is
impossible
they're very much likely to be wrong
first of all do you agree with that
second of all
what have you changed your mind on what
have you been wrong about Robert
if anything okay so
so in the 80s I worked on cosmic strings
as a competitor to inflation
and uh this the boomerang data proved
that this was wrong
so now on a smaller scale I often do
make mistakes in calculations and and
then uh I have to realize that um there
was a there was a mistake and usually
hopefully you catch them when you repeat
calculations many times but uh there was
there are some cases when you don't
catch them and then you have to uh
live up to it and write a neuratum
so there's one time when when I wrote a
paper with a friend of mine and uh then
we got a a letter from a Stony Brook
Professor saying that we know we were
wrong and uh well we argued for a while
we didn't we didn't just obviously
believe it but then eventually we we um
we agreed we had been wrong and then we
walked in a rotten and then that's Sony
book Professor wrote back and said I'm
very happy that you wrote this erratum
fortunately I've never had to do that in
my career
what what that what that Sony Brook uh
Professor had actually done and then I
realized why
well I have a special bit of affection
tell you something that why is she my de
facto PhD advisor Bill press yes what he
told me
the advice that he gave me he said that
if you want to do something really new
you have to risk being wrong but you see
when I'm working on this Matrix
cosmology which I presented a little bit
of yeah I may be wrong there may be
I'm since I'm not a string test I'm
going out on the limb
so but it's exciting
and so you have to risk being wrong and
if I'm proven wrong then I could make
sure
sometimes as a when I'm wearing my
podcasting hat I will say in the name of
one of my mentors in podcasting James
alticher he says I never published
something I'm not afraid to publish
I think that's an interesting rule it
doesn't mean that you should do stuff
that's knowingly wrong or risky and or
unethical but nevertheless it's good to
have that self-doubt and uh but also
simultaneously to have a little bit of
swagger to have confidence that you've
been right in the past and look back not
on your you know to-do list uh but on
your have done list uh so the last
question Robert uh brings us back uh to
the very beginning and this is going to
be soliciting uh advice to your former
self or a young person as I said a lot
of young men young women listen to this
podcast
um I want to ask you in the name of Sir
Arthur C Clarke he said the following he
said the only way to determine the
limits of the possible is to go beyond
them into the impossible so I'd like to
ask you
advice to your 20 year old self if I
could have known you the same age that I
started at Brown
um what advice would you give that young
Robert or anybody as a stand-in for for
you to give you the courage to do as
you've done to go into the impossible
the name of this podcast
[Music]
make a promising area to try to explore
and exploit
and not be led by
other motivations perhaps
no
but you see
I I gave this young Robert
only two options one option a business
career and the other option uh being a
teacher for example at the community
college or in in Quebec or in
Switzerland it would be gymnasium
I didn't give a person the option of of
wanting definitely a research
professorship at a major university
because you didn't think it was possible
or it was so out of the realm of
possibility or it was just two grandios
at the time why did you not give that
young Robert that opportunity it's
see it's something that you can you can
dream of but you shouldn't consider that
to be a probably
possibility
I didn't
yeah me neither I I didn't even believe
it until maybe after I became a
professor and actually I I don't think
I mean you touched on this briefly but
uh I'm worried about the future uh right
now we had a faculty search for a
teaching faculty we got 200 applications
for one position
I joke that you know there are more
people playing in the professional NBA
or let me turn it to the Canadians up
there in Montreal uh there's way more
people that are you know in the National
Hockey League or in the Canadian hockey
league then our cosmology professors and
yet and yet there's perhaps five times
as many people who want to be that that
are in the minor leagues if you will and
I'm not saying that pejoratively I'm
saying there are post-docs are there too
many of them are there too many graduate
students I I think overall there's not
enough I think I would love to have a
million cosmology students and and
post-docs and professors if it could be
sustained because I think that could
lead to our flourishing as a species and
physicist in general mathematicians it's
a but right now
I think we might have too many what do
you think
I think we have
too many people who are dreaming only of
a academic career at a major research
University
and you don't have enough who are who
would be eager to go into a teaching
career at a lower level
well I I have to say Robert that you are
in no small part to blame
or or to to thank for setting me on a
path as a paradigm again I never thought
you know Stefan and I we were in
Barrison Holly room you know 144 in the
basement dungeon down there we used to
call it
and and you'd come by every now and then
um and you're inspiring to us uh but we
never thought we'd be professors him in
an Ivy League school me at a at a top
research University as well we never
thought we'd be professors but that
didn't stop us from being fascinated by
what you were teaching us inside and
outside of the classroom and so on
behalf of of me and my students and my
my uh my future students to come I want
to thank you so much not just for being
on the podcast and I hope this will only
be a part one and I hope part two will
be in person at some point because I I
miss you and I would love to be uh you
know to see you in person uh but I hope
this is just the beginning of our
rekindling our our connection if you'll
if you'll again indulge me with your
patented forbearance
but I'm very proud of what you've done
so it's always nice to see students
um
succeed
and uh that that that's one of the
pleasures of being a professor
succeed and having fun and doing your
thing
it is it is a great great source of
satisfaction Robert brandenberger
Professor uh long time uh inspiration to
many many young generations of
cosmologists and future and in the
present Robert thank you so much for
joining us enjoy your evening and I do
hope as I say we'll see it be in person
not too long from now
thank you very much for the invitation
thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]